and you know what else
by the way is not working for
republicans
having rick scott senator from my state
down here in florida
running the national republican
senatorial committee
now the national republican senatorial
committee the nrsc
is also the fundraising arm
of the senate republicans
and they got a problem right now
the problem is
they all want to know where the heck the
money has gone
because they have raised 173 million
dollars this cycle it's a lot of money
and they got a lot of contentious races
out there that they need to be spending
this money on
there's just one
problem it's almost all gone
rick scott apparently bad with money
still
and i'll expand on that still in just a
moment but
the republican party
in the senate now only has 28 million
dollars cash on hand
like the situation is so bad that last
week
again right as we're heading into
general election mode they announced
they were withdrawing 10 million dollars
worth of ads in crucial swing states
like pennsylvania
and wisconsin
two seats republicans desperately need
to hold on to
but right now polls are not looking so
good for them
and they had to pull out their ad buys
because they only have 28 million
they're not going to go blow another 10
million you know a third almost of what
they've got left
on two races
so the big question these republicans
want to know right now is rick scott
where is the money
what the heck have you done with a
hundred and what 50 somewhat almost
million dollars where is it bud
so far no answers
but
i think it's important to point out the
fact once again and i'm sure most
everybody knows that but
it seems a little relevant here right
rick scott before he got into politics
was a businessman he's a businessman
that started a health care company
a health care company that later on down
the road
would commit the largest to date
medicare fraud in the history of the
united states over a billion
dollars
and the fraud was apparently so bad that
rick scott in his deposition had to
plead the fifth amendment i think
something of what 75 times
i know that's not as much as trump you
know having depleted 440 times in front
of leticia james a couple weeks ago
but 75 times pleading the fifth so you
don't
incriminate yourself into that massive
medicare fraud that's a lot
and so somewhere somewhere along the
lines
somewhere down the road once rick scott
got into politics
governor of florida for eight years now
he's in the senate republicans looked at
him and said hey remember that time
this guy's company oversaw the biggest
medicare fraud in history right clearly
they can't be trusted with money at all
what if we put him in charge of all of
our money
and then wouldn't you know it all their
money disappeared
now before anybody jumps to any
conclusions please understand i am not
in any way
suggesting that rick scott stole this
money you know put that thought out of
your head right now
right
that's probably the safe thing to do we
shouldn't
we shouldn't jump to any conclusions and
by the way we're not if rick scott had
taken
you know 140 million dollars from the
republicans 145 i think is the exact
number um they'd know
right there are receipts for these kinds
of things rick scott could not have
taken the money but he is bad with money
okay that's something we can all pretty
much agree on at this point
so why in the heck republicans decided
to put this guy in charge of the money
still blows my mind
what because he's independently wealthy
he's got a net worth of hundreds of
millions of dollars
would you think he was going to fill up
your campaign coffers with his own bank
account heck no
oh because he knows a lot of rich people
you all know a lot of rich people
you didn't need him to be in this
position
and now you've put yourself
in the position of having a guy
that already shouldn't have been trusted
with money i mean pleading the fifth 75
times that that's 75 major red flags
right there
but you still looked at him
and you said you know what
let's give him the purse strings
let's let him be the standard bearer for
the republican party and
just spend our money do whatever we've
raised a lot of it and now
in the final stretch of these midterm
races
republicans are looking and saying oh
god
we're out of money
we got to take a quick break i am fair
and cousins if you want more from me you
can find me on youtube on my two
channels youtube.com slash the ring of
fire and youtube.com fair and balanced
i'm also on facebook twitter and
instagram at farron balanced
this is the david pakman show i'm farron
cousins in for david pakman and we'll be
right back
something in your home that you use
every day contributes to deforestation
and climate change and that's toilet
paper in the u.s alone over 30 million
trees each year are required to meet
toilet paper demands contributing to
deforestation soil erosion devastating
loss of biodiversity our sponsor real
paper makes sustainable toilet paper
that is 100
made from bamboo a bamboo stock keeps
growing it can be harvested forever it
means that the soil and the ecosystem
aren't disrupted no carbon removing
trees are cut down the paper industry
has a massive effect on deforestation
and climate change but you alone using
bamboo toilet paper can make a positive
impact because for the toilet paper that
just one american uses in their lifetime
hundreds of trees are required
put an end to that right now with real
paper the best part is the stuff is
really great it's just normal soft
toilet paper real paper loves the david
pakman show they're giving my audience
30 off your first order and free
shipping when you go to real paper dot
com slash pacman and use the code pacman
at checkout the link is down below